Я трошки шкодую, що в школі я
пропускала заняття,
не вчилася так,
як могла б навчатися зараз.
Вітаю!
Мене звати Бабенко Артур,
і сьогодні ми з вами будемо вивчати
буремні події російської революції
на українських землях
в період з 1905 по 1907 роки.
Сподіваюсь, що буде вам цікаво, ну і
про основні особливості дізнаємося зараз.
Одразу хочу зазначити,
що ось ця жінка на презентації
ніякого відношення до революції не має,
і я її додав, тому що це досить
гарний фон.
Тому ніяких теорій змов
або розмірковування
щодо важливості цієї постаті робити
не потрібно.
Кажу про всяк випадок.
Давайте зараз спробуємо пригадати,
що ми взагалі знаємо про революції,
бо ми вивчаємо з вами історію в 9 класі,
і ви протягом вивчення історії
в 7, 8 класах чудово знаєте вже про те,
що таке революція, чудово пам’ятаєте
революції в різних країнах,
тому давайте спробуємо згадати,
а що ж це таке.
Можливо, нам допоможе наша гостя і
спробує сформулювати, що ж таке революція.
- Як Ви розумієте цей термін?
- Немає простіших питань?
- Простіші будуть потім.
- Ну, я піду?
- Ні, не треба, залишайтесь.
- Давайте, тоді розповісте ви.
Давайте пригадаємо, що ж таке революція.
Подивіться уважно на ці два зображення
і спробуйте сказати,
чи є події на картинці ліворуч і на
картинці праворуч революціями,
чи, можливо, революція зображена тільки
на одній з цих картин?
- Слава, як Ви думаєте?
- На першій, мені здається.
- Так, на першій картинці ми чітко бачимо,
що тут руйнування йде,
вогонь, люди виступають.
Картинка номер два, вона більш така мирна.
Якщо пригадати нашу історію з вами
в 8 класі, історію нового часу,
то можна сказати, що і це також
є революцією.
Перше зображення – це в нас якраз
захоплення Бастилії,
і це початок Французької революції,
дуже відомої,
яку ми з вами вчили на початку 9 класу,
і друга подія – це промислова революція
в Англії.
Отже, який можна зробити перший висновок?
Революція – це не завжди щось криваве,
щось таке злочинне і негативне.
Інколи революції – це досить мирний
і навіть прогресивний процес.
Відповідно, революцій буває декілька.
Бувають революції політичні,
коли населення повстає, щоб змінити владу.
От якраз революція Французька – це була
така політична революція.
Також бувають революції технічні
або технологічні,
і це якраз, як приклад, революція
в Англії,
завдяки якій суспільство перейшло
до активного розвитку промисловості.
До речі, можете пригадати, як саме
відбувалась революція в Англії.
Отже, давайте зробимо перший і дуже
важливий висновок, що ж таке революція?
Революція – це якісь швидкі,
кардинальні зміни.
Відповідно, коли ми вивчатимемо події
революції 1905 року на території України,
ми якраз і будемо говорити про початок цих
важливих кардинальних змін.
Наша тема буде складатися з двох частин,
тобто, з двох уроків.
На сьогоднішньому уроці ми будемо говорити
саме про події, про повстання,
про людські хвилювання, які були,
а на другому уроці будемо вже говорити
про українське національне піднесення,
бо кожна революція – це певні можливості.
Ми, власне, будемо говорити на другому
уроці про ті нові можливості,
які виникли для української культури
і українського національного руху.
Перш за все, ми повинні зрозуміти,
які були причини цієї революції,
тобто, чому населення повстало.
Розглянемо на прикладі декількох
важливих галузей.
Перше, звісно, це економіка.
Ви знаєте, що революції починаються,
здебільшого,
через певну скруту в житті людини
і через те, що людям щось не подобається
в державі,
і державна влада ніяк не реагує на
ці виклики.
Відповідно, перша проблема, яка виникла –
суперечності в процесі модернізації.
Ви пам’ятаєте, що в Росії в період другої
половини 19 століття
почали проводитись реформи,
але реформи були непослідовними.
Вони залишили багатьох людей
невдоволеними,
тому що селяни не отримали землі,
робітники не отримали гарні умови
для праці, і,
таким чином, люди очікували певних нових
змін, але вони, на жаль, не відбувалися.
Окрім цього, залишалися великі поміщицькі
землеволодіння,
що дуже не подобалось селянам, оскільки
селяни хотіли земель,
а землі знаходились в руках, ну,
поміщиків.
Відповідно, ви бачите, що частина
населення дуже хоче змін,
в тому числі економічних.
Втім, не тільки економіка.
Сама система в Російській імперії була
надзвичайно застарілою,
була феодальною.
Російський імператор мав дуже
велику кількість повноважень
і робив усе, що йому заманеться.
Населення ніяк, в принципі, не могло
вплинути на його рішення,
на його діяльність.
Навіть більше, авторитет царя саме в цей
час починає поступово знижуватись.
Нагадаю вам, що царем на той час був
Микола Другий.
Власне, авторитет дуже сильно впав під час
Російсько-японської війни.
Вона почалася в 1904 році.
Ця війна здавалася для російської влади
досить простою.
Уявіть собі, величезна Російська імперія
і невеличка Японія.
Однак японці змогли перевернути хід подій,
японці перемагали одну битву за іншою…
Перемагали російську армію.
Росія декілька разів відправляла свій
флот, який японці успішно знищували,
і коли населення дізналося про перші
поразки з боку російської влади,
вони почали у всьому винуватити
звісно кого? – владу.
Таким чином, влада або слова влади
і дії влади,
вони втрачали будь-яку вагу
в очах населення.
Відповідно, Російсько-японська війна
дуже сильно вдарила по авторитету царя.
Ну і остання причина – це соціальна.
У кожному суспільстві у всі часи існують
бідні і багаті, існує розподіл населення,
але дуже важливо, щоб у людей
були можливості зростати,
покращувати своє становище.
От в Російській імперії того часу люди,
фактично, були приречені,
якщо людина народжувалася селянином,
причому бідним,
то таким вона і залишалася.
Відповідно, якщо людина народжувалася
в сім'ї робітника,
то вона також працювала робітником,
причому в дуже поганих умовах.
Ці умови не відрізнялися від умов,
коли батьки працювали, ну, і коли діти.
Дуже важливим моментом було, звісно,
питання національної ідентичності.
Росія того часу, як будь-яка імперія,
включала в себе різні народи,
в тому числі і велику частину українців.
Українці на початку 20 століття вже
прагнули розвивати свою культуру,
свою мову,
але, як ви знаєте, російська влада цього
не давала і не дозволяла.
Українці намагаються мирно захищати
свої права,
протестів особливих не піднімають,
але все одно в душі, всередині у людей
визріває невдоволення.
Люди очікують того моменту,
коли можна його буде сказати привселюдно.
Такий момент настав.
Момент настав якраз у 1905 році,
19-05 запам’ятати неважко.
Цього року в Росії, власне,
і почалася революція.
Початок цієї події пов'язаний з діяльністю
ось цього чоловіка.
Його звали Георгій Гапон.
Він був звичайним священиком з території,
до речі, Полтавської губернії,
потім переїхав до Петербурга,
шукаючи кращої долі, кращого життя.
Він був тим чоловіком, який хотів,
певно, відомості,
і він хотів здобути певний вплив.
Він почав у Петербурзі проводити таку
роз’яснювальну роботу серед робітників,
читав проповіді різноманітні,
розповідав їм про життя-буття,
як треба працювати, як треба захищати,
в тому числі, свої права,
і він навіть потрапив у поле зору
російських спецслужб.
Ну, оскільки він вже мав вплив серед
робітників,
звісно, поліція повинна була всі ці
процеси контролювати.
Зрештою, він став настільки відомим,
якраз всередині робітничого класу,
що більшість людей почали вважати
його своєрідним авторитетом.
Якраз у 1905 році він перший очолив ось
цей рух невдоволених людей.
Як все почалось?
Третє січня 1905 року,
завершився Новий рік,
люди вийшли знов на роботу,
але після Нового року нічого не змінилось,
робота була такою самою поганою,
зарплати такими ж самими низькими
і тому населення, звісно,
почало страйкувати.
Перший страйк відбувся на Путилівському
заводі, а це завод в Петербурзі.
Робітники просто вийшли, щоб сказати
своєму роботодавцю про те,
щоб він зменшив кількість робочого часу,
ну, і збільшив заробітну платню.
Керівник цього заводу був
звичайним менеджером,
він цього робити, в принципі, не міг.
У нього було завдання, щоб виробляти
продукцію і щоб працівники працювали.
Тому він сказав: «Хлопці, розходимось по
своїх робочих місцях», – і все.
Робітників це дуже, дуже обурило.
Вони навіть почали його звинувачувати
і хотіли побити.
Він ледве уник цього.
На цьому повстання не завершилося.
Солідарні акції повстання відбулися
і на території інших заводів.
Піком цього протистояння стала подія,
яка почалась 9 січня 1905 року.
Цю подію в історії прийнято називати
«Кривавою неділею».
Що ж відбулося в цей час?
Георгій Гапон як керівник якраз
робітників, як їхній моральний авторитет,
написав петицію, з якою робітники підійшли
до Зимового палацу в місті Петербурзі.
На той момент всередині російської влади
існували різні такі теорії змови,
зокрема одна з теорій змов була в тому,
що, нібито,
проти російського царя готується замах,
нібито, навіть хочуть здійснити державний
переворот.
Тому ось цю звичайну мирну акцію
і звичайну мирну петицію
керівники російської влади розцінили як
певний замах, як певну небезпеку.
Було віддано наказ (його віддав не
Микола ІІ, а його найближчий родич),
було віддано наказ розігнати демонстрацію.
Втім, на жаль, ця демонстрація була
розігнана такими, умовно кажучи,
«кращими методами тодішньої
російсько-імператорської влади»,
тобто, людей просто-на-просто почали бити
і насильно виганяти з території міста.
Сама акція тривала декілька днів,
було декілька напрямів
або центрів цього повстанського руху
на території Петербурга.
Здебільшого, розгін відбувався
таким чином:
група козаків вривалася в натовп
і била людей,
а інколи і стріляла по людях.
Здебільшого, люди втікали і більше
не збиралися.
Втім, були моменти, коли люди починали
чинити супротив.
Ось на одному з таких центрів люди навіть
захопили зброю,
і почалася перестрілка між протестуючими
і козаками.
Цю перестрілку побачив відомий російський
художник Сєров.
Він малював портрети російських царів
і був дуже таким поважним.
Він потім написав в своїх спогадах,
що коли він побачив цю подію,
він про себе подумав, що більше жодного
портрету царя не намалює.
Він не намалював потім жодного портрету
російських царів.
Ця подія – Кривава неділя – вона стала
надзвичайно важливою і переломною.
Саме тоді суспільство зрозуміло, що
російська влада в обличчі російського царя
знаходиться на одному боці барикад,
а люди знаходяться на іншому боці барикад.
Саме від цієї події бере відлік
російська революція 1905 року.
Коли про події Кривавої неділі дізналися
на всіх куточках Російської імперії,
велика кількість робітників підтримала тих
людей, які вийшли в Петербурзі,
і також почалися страйки.
Зокрема, страйкували на території України.
Спочатку приблизно 70 тисяч людей, потім
кількість страйкуючих збільшилась
до 100 тисяч людей.
Робітники висували досить прості умови,
ви їх можете бачити в цій петиції,
з якою виступили робітники в Петербурзі –
це збільшення заробітних плат,
покращення умов праці і,
в основному, це все.
Окрім цього, звісно, були ще прохання,
щоб демократизувати Російську імперію,
створити щось на зразок парламенту,
тобто, Державну Думу.
Російська влада спочатку категорично
відмовлялася все це виконувати.
Навіть більше, будь-які повстання,
будь-які мітинги
дуже жорстко розганялися російською
владою.
Спочатку російська держава особливо
не звертала на все це уваги,
але до моменту, поки не повстали
військові.
Ви, до речі, я думаю, знаєте, що опора
будь-якого режиму – це що? – військо.
Поки військо підтримує, неважливо кого,
хто це – цар, президент, султан, будь-хто,
влада буде триматись.
Як тільки військо переходить на бік
протестуючих,
влада вже починає потрошку сипатись.
Власне, якраз влітку 1905 року відбувся
протест військових.
При чому протест відбувся якраз
на українських територіях,
на панцернику «Потьомкін».
Дуже відома подія, зараз трошки розкажу
як це все було,
щоб ви зрозуміли сам контекст цього
повстання.
Панцерник «Потьомкін» належав до
чорноморського флоту
і його відправили якраз до території
Одеси,
щоб загрозливим видом приборкувати
повстання
або будь-який рух робітників на території
самої Одеси.
Вийшло так, що на самому панцернику
виникло повстання.
Як це відбулося?
Кухар (кок) поїхав до Одеси, щоб
купити продукти, приготувати щось поїсти.
Оскільки Одеса була охоплена повстанням,
яке тривало вже декілька тижнів,
більшість продуктів були зіпсовані.
Кок подумав, що щось же готувати треба,
тому він купив зіпсоване м'ясо
і прибув на корабель і приготував їжу.
Якраз тут вийшов цей критичний момент:
із зіпсованого м'яса їжу він приготував
тільки матросам.
Офіцери їли досить нормальну і якісну їжу.
Коли матроси побачили, чим їх хочуть
нагодувати,
вони, звісно, підняли повстання,
і вони спочатку просто відмовились їсти
цей суп з м’ясом не дуже якісним.
Лише один матрос із
задоволенням його поїв,
не знаю, як із задоволенням, але деякі
джерела пишуть, що із задоволенням.
Можливо, він просто хотів вислужитись
перед офіцерами.
- Може, просто їсти хотів.
- Так, може бути.
Суть у тому, що капітан дізнався,
що матроси не їдять цю їжу,
вистроїв їх на палубі і сказав
пошикуватися в два ряди:
праворуч стати тим, хто буде їсти цей суп,
а ліворуч тим, хто його їсти не буде.
Люди вишикувались, більша частина, звісно,
стала ліворуч, відмовившись їсти це все,
однак потім капітан викликав інших
офіцерів і наказав принести брезент.
Це означало, що він збирається розстріляти
всіх тих,
хто не хотів їсти цей зіпсований суп.
Коли матроси дізнались про це і допоки
виносили брезент,
вони намагалися перейти на правий бік.
Що все-таки, ну добре вже, можна і з'їсти.
Капітан сказав: «Ні, вже все, час вийшов».
Тоді матроси зрозуміли, що їм діватися
нікуди, вони підіймають повстання,
причому підняли повстання абсолютно всі.
Вбивають більшість офіцерів,
деяка частина офіцерів, невелика
кількість перейшла на бік матросів,
але, тим не менше, це повстання, ця подія,
вона показала,
що навіть військові невдоволені своїм
становищем.
До речі, матроси вбили не тільки більшість
офіцерів, але і того єдиного матроса,
який з'їв цей суп.
Відповідно, ця подія, вона стала
символом того,
що військові не хочуть також жити в таких
умовах, в яких вони живуть.
Це був перший збройний виступ військових.
До речі, його підтримали військові на
деяких кораблях,
але це ще не було таке загальноросійське
військове повстання.
До речі, потім з цим панцерником відбулась
така подія:
матроси ще поплавали трошки по морю,
а коли в них закінчилися ресурси,
вони поїхали до Румунії і втекли в Європу.
Тому що вони розуміли, що їх в гіршому
випадку просто розстріляють.
Повстання продовжувалися.
Окрім військових і окрім робітників, також
поступово починають повставати селяни.
- Слава, як Ви думаєте, на кого саме був
направлений гнів селян?
Тобто, кого вони напевне ненавиділи
більше всіх?
- Владу!
- Правильно, а ще вони ненавиділи тих,
хто володів найбільшою кількістю земель.
Це, звісно, поміщики.
Тому селяни почали активно нападати
на поміщицькі землеволодіння,
спалювати їхні хати і знищувати все їхнє
майно.
Окрім цього, селяни, звісно, ділили
землі і, таким чином,
намагалися отримати хоча б якусь частинку
власності для себе,
однак не завжди це в них виходило.
Після того, як російська влада зрозуміла,
що повстання приборкати не вдасться
і що треба йти на певні поступки,
російський імператор нарешті видає дуже
важливий документ.
Він називався «Маніфест 17 жовтня».
Цей маніфест дійсно був надзвичайно
революційним як на ті часи.
Суть його зводилася до трьох основних
пунктів.
Пункт номер 1: влада погодилась створити
законодавчий орган – Державну Думу.
Навіщо це потрібно?
Законодавчий орган – це той орган,
який контролює дії влади.
У більшості європейських країн подібні
законодавчі органи були створені
ще в 13 столітті.
В Російській імперії навіть
на початку 20 століття його не було.
Тому люди виступали за те, щоб були хоча б
якісь обмеження з боку народу,
і ось Державна Дума повинна була виступати
цим голосом народу,
який би обмежував царя і пропонував би
йому якісь нові реформи.
Окрім цього, цар нарешті надав
громадянські права.
До речі, це ті права, за які боролись ще
під час Французької революції.
Французи їх вибороли.
В Російській імперії ці права стали
реальністю,
зазначимо, тільки на невеличкий час,
в часи революції.
Що це за права?
По-перше, свобода друку, тобто,
відсутність цензури,
також це свобода зібрань, спілок
і свобода совісті.
- До речі, пригадайте, що таке свобода
совісті? Пригадали?
- Що таке свобода совісті?
- Свобода совісті – це свобода
віросповідання.
Відповідно, завдяки наданню цих
громадянських прав
дуже активізувалася суспільна діяльність.
Друкувалися газети, журнали, люди нарешті
почали говорити те,
про що раніше їм забороняли казати.
Ну і третє, було надано загальне виборче
право.
Видаючи цей маніфест, Микола ІІ
сподівався, що він зможе подолати
ось це народне невдоволення і трошки
знизити напруження цієї революції.
Дійсно, частково це йому вдалося.
Частина людей, прочитавши цей маніфест,
надзвичайно сильно зраділа.
Ви можете побачити зараз картину
Іллі Рєпіна.
Вона так і називається
«Маніфест 17 жовтня».
Видно таку всенародну радість.
Однак зраділа лише деяка частина людей.
Інші не побачили ніякого полегшення,
і тому революційні події продовжуються.
Пік революції якраз припадає на період
жовтня-грудня 1905 року.
На жаль, в цей час рівень такого
невдоволення, рівень насилля збільшується.
Зокрема, після підписання цього маніфесту
відбувається дуже велика кількість
погромів, в тому числі і єврейських.
На жаль, це явище було типовим для
Російської імперії того часу,
ну і не тільки для російської,
але там також було.
Суть його зводилась до того, що єврейські
крамниці, будинки грабувалися,
євреїв били, інколи вбивали.
Ці погроми, на жаль, ніяк не
ліквідовувались владою.
Тобто, влада інколи навіть підтримувала.
Власне, один з таких дуже великих погромів
відбувся в Одесі,
невдовзі після підписання цього маніфесту.
На території України були утворені
чорносотенні організації.
Чорносотенці – це представники таких
ультранаціоналістичних,
монархічних організацій.
Вони виступали за теорію самодержавства,
народності
і вважали, що існують тільки російський
народ,
а українського, білоруського та інших
народів не існує в принципі.
Тому чорносотенці і
були якраз виконавцями
деяких антинаціональних дій.
Зокрема, чорносотенці намагалися знищувати
або перешкоджати діяльності
різних українських національних течій
і течій інших народностей, зокрема євреїв.
В Одесі відбулися масові погроми
буквально 18-19 жовтня,
вони тривали декілька днів, що дуже
важливо, влада взагалі ніяк не реагувала.
Я вам зараз зачитаю цитату очевидця цих
подій,
вона якраз вам покаже всю ту страшну
картину, яка там відбувалася.
Ось свідчення очевидця:
«Було багато різних людей. Озброєних,
з ломами і палицями.
Серед них я помітив декілька місцевих
жителів, яких я знаю особисто.
Але не можу назвати їхні імена.
Ми всі просили їх узяти наше майно,
але залишити нам наше життя.
Відразу же у дворі я помітив молодого
офіцера і двох солдат з рушницями.
Я вискочив на балкон і звернувся до
офіцера, який там стояв, з словами:
«Допоможіть нам!». Але офіцер, почувши
мої слова, крикнув воякам: «Стріляй!».
Тоді останній увірвався в нашу кімнату
із рушницями і почав стріляти в нас»
Тобто, ми з вами бачимо, що навіть
представники російської влади
підтримували ці погроми, замість того,
щоб намагатися їх якось придушити.
Втім, треба віддати належне єврейському
і українському населенню,
бо євреї створювали загони самооборони,
а до них приєднувалися і українці.
Таким чином ці загони намагалися
стримувати ці злочинні дії чорносотенців.
Дійсно, були успіхи,
навіть під час деяких погромів ті ж самі
загони єврейської самооборони,
ну скажімо так, вбивали більше
чорносотенців, ніж навпаки.
Таким чином населення показувало,
що нас чіпати не треба,
можемо дати відсіч, і цю відсіч давало.
Окрім погромів, на території України
в період з жовтня по грудень 1905 року
продовжувалися повстання.
Зокрема, було декілька важливих повстань.
Це повстання, знову ж таки, військових
на крейсері Очаків.
Його очолив лейтенант Шмідт, який себе
самовільно назвав капітаном другого рангу
і підняв матросів на це повстання.
До повстання приєдналися матроси
12 кораблів,
але згодом його (повстання) вдалося
також придушити.
Знову ж таки, це повстання показує,
що військові проти певних дій
російської влади.
Також відбулося ще повстання військових
на території Києва,
повстання київського саперного гарнізону.
Нічого страшного там спочатку не було,
військові просто хотіли пройтись Києвом
в знак протесту, просто звичайний мітинг,
але проти цих мітингуючих військових,
знову ж таки, відправили в загони козаків,
які призвели до збройної сутички.
Під час цієї збройної сутички повстання,
знову ж таки, було придушене.
Ну і останнє – селяни, як без них.
Селяни продовжували повставати,
і найбільшим повстанням взагалі під час
цієї революції було повстання,
знову ж таки, на українських землях.
Це повстання в селищі Великі Сорочинці,
грудень 1905 року.
Суть його зводилась до того, що одного
сільського вчителя, з цього селища,
що він, нібито, агітує за революцію.
Його місцева влада посадила за грати, і
місцеві жителі виступили на його підтримку
При чому всю місцеву владу при повстанні
також вони посадили за грати.
Проти повстанців, знову ж таки, виступили
козаки,
які намагалися придушити повстання
і взяти в полон тих людей,
які були лідерами цього.
Однак перший напад козаків було зупинено,
причому вбили керівника цих козаків.
Потім був ще один напад цих козаків,
і під час цього другого нападу повстання
все-таки вдалося придушити.
Бо у селян було що? – вила,
натхнення і коси,
а у козаків була і вогнепальна зброя,
і інші види зброї.
Тому, відповідно, ціла низка цих повстань
показала,
що люди все одно продовжують боротися
за свої права.
Всі ці повстання були стихійними,
вони були неорганізованими,
не було єдиного лідера, який би зміг
об’єднати всі верстви населення,
тому згодом російській владі вдалось
поступово придушити ці повстання,
і революція поступово пішла на спад.
Однак все одно ця революція була важливою,
оскільки прийняття маніфесту,
оскільки людські повстання,
вони показали владі, що люди вимагають
виконання їхніх прав.
Поступово російська влада пішла на
поступки.
На другому уроці ми будемо говорити з вами
про діяльність різних українських
національних лідерів,
про українське національне життя
в часи революції.
Воно стало можливим завдяки саме цій
події.
Про те, які газети писали, які журнали,
як українці діяли вже в Державній Думі
про це все буде йти мова далі.
Тому який можна зробити висновок?
Революція – це, здебільшого, дуже жорстока
подія, дуже насильницька,
але, тим не менш, тільки шляхом революції
дуже часто вдається здобути певні зміни.
На цьому у нас все, але не забудьте,
зараз ми пройдемо декілька тестів.
- Отже, питання номер один.
- Неділя, кривава неділя.
- Так, правильно.
Правильна відповідь – кривава неділя.
- Так. Далі, питання номер два.
Правильною відповіддю тут є?
- Чорносотенці.
- Правильно, Слава, хвалю. Так, це вони.
Питання номер три.
- Жовтень!
- Правильно. Це жовтень 1905 року,
варіант В.
Дякую вам дуже за увагу, за те,
що виконували тести!
Це лише перша частина, друга частина,
про українську революцію,
буде на наступному уроці.
Тому тримаємось! Щастя вам і натхнення.
До зустрічі на нових уроках!
- Щиро дякую, дуже цікаво було.
- Дякую Вам, що прийшли.
В мене урок історії пройшов чудово!
По-перше, він розповідав про Одесу,
а я, взагалі, одеситка.
Про те, що там відбувалося.
Я сиділа і думала про те, що я одеситка,
і я нічого про це не знаю.
Діти, вчіть у школі все, що тільки можна
вчити!
Потім, коли ви виростете і станете такими
дорослими, як я,
ви будете дуже сильно шкодувати про те,
що не вчили певні предмети,
а певні предмети – значить, все!